here we go let's try efore Heiser was
the guy who picked at number 70 from the
number range let's go with the Sicilian
and I've been playing this quite a bit
the Rhossili mo so I'm gonna stick with
it and maybe gain some more experience
potentially damaging the queenside
structure I'm gonna I'm gonna do that if
I don't do that right away the black
connects Knights and then is there to
recapture so with this structural change
what will I look to do next I'm going to
play Queen 2e to immediately it seems a
bit I think this is a an exception to
the rule of not bringing your queen out
early in the chess game she can't really
be harassed from the e 2 square and I'm
doing this to facilitate an eventually 5
advance I may want to also consider a d3
well d3 is going to be played I don't
want to play d4 because it helps to
undone it will under the black pawns my
main aim with now this resulting
structure will be to show that this
bishop is a bad piece so let me do this
first I don't want to commit just yet
with my king not that I would really be
castling kingside
because of this open B file I think
that's simply unnecessary but I think
that there might be an idea and well I
was thinking if the knight played to g7
c7 g6 there's this idea of h4 h5 to
interfere with that idea not the case
here so I think this is a good idea
let's establish this structure and you
know what if i play my Knight to c3 and
d4 is played I can't play to a4 because
of Queen a4 check so in other words when
I do play my Knight to c3 I want to be
able to meet
a structural change of d4 with night a
for where I could put pressure on c5
this may turn out to be my plan to put
pressure on the c5 square and I could do
that with ensuing moves such as Knight
c3 let me first get castled however
otherwise again the 93 d4 Knight a4
Queen a5 with check-in my knight would
be dead so now I'm ready to develop my
knight and now I could get there hang on
for a second though I think I push first
night here yeah this is an important
detail actually I'm taking pause right
here because there's potential for
structural changes and depending on the
pawn structure that it really dictates
the the rest of the game so I want to
make sure I end up with a good structure
if I play Knight c3 the thing that I've
been talking about for a bunch 93 d4
Knight a4 and then e 5 this Bishop I
want to keep him dead but he would then
become alive so first 'if I've don't
even allow this pawn to move and that
has a direct influence on this guy now
hang on maybe I still don't do this just
yet I think I'm going to transition
maybe I don't want my knight to be
kicked over here on a4 in fact it could
always be challenged with tonight b6 and
I don't want to capture because it
repairs the pawn structure gives the rip
play so I'm gonna transition I'm gonna
come over in this direction and support
this pawn if I play Knight c3 now I want
to be able to meet not d4 with the
Knight e4 however if I do that right
away
Nighy 4 would interference with my
defense of the e5 square so I need to
have my bishop and Knight here to defend
the pawn something like this advance
might be available at some point I don't
think it's good now but keep in mind he
is unprotected and so in advance like f5
if I'm to capture there is going takes
bishop but again I don't think
that is a good thing to be running
forward with so let me complete
development I'm now fully developed
black still needs to move this bishop
before they are fully developed as well
and the reason that I'm seeing this
advance wouldn't be a good idea whether
it be f6 or f5 is because I'm able to
capture and have pressure on the bishop
so my main aim well I believe still be
to make sure this bishop does not have a
good life
keep this bishop under lock and key
don't let him get activated if there's
more pressure placed on c4 with Bishop
e6 I simply played this and well my
candidate moves our b3 I'm definitely
not considering tying down a piece to
the defense of the pond so if anything
I'll let my puns defend my pawns when
they're attacked so b3 I'm considering
I'm also considering h4 h5 h6 using this
guy to soften up the black King side
structure I don't feel that there's a
need to play b3 just yet let me I don't
like having my queen having to defend
upon so let me just do this right away
if my knight is attacked since he's now
unprotected Queen here rook a to C one
will be the one that I moved to defend
the night because I want this rook
around to maybe play to one or d1 I'm
not sure he really knows where he
belongs and now let me continue with
this I don't know that my rooks have a
clear well yeah I don't think that they
know where they belong just yet we don't
have really any pawn exchanges do we so
I didn't play h4 to just sit there I'm
doing this again to try and soften up
the black king side structure so this
guy flinched and what could I be doing
next Queen here there's a fork hmm let
me do this
because eventually I might be
threatening to do something like capture
it's a very timely capture and then put
pressure on this pot now if there's this
structural change
I was talking about playing here but I
might find it better to play to a four
because that would prove that would mean
that this rook would not get any play on
the Queen side I would have essentially
after d4 Knight a4 I would have the
Queen side on lock down and then I could
look to play on the the Kings section
Kings side of the board play with this
pawn having the space advantage this
pawn on e5 and I guess this Knight is
looking to reroute on the beat
Foursquare they are going into reverse
do I really want to commit my Jeep on
let me let me see if I could get my
opponent to flinch
maybe that Bishop is going to come back
yes he is okay I'm gonna go just a
single step maybe I can do King g2 rook
up and over get my rook right here seems
like that that comes at a snail's pace
but I don't know that my opponent has a
successful pawn move that helps their
position now that move kind of scares me
let me bump my King up I'm never keep in
mind I'm never considering really
capturing only only what they concrete
line would I be considering some capture
because I'm feel I would just be helping
my opponent so let me let me do this let
me get my Queen over here what my
opponent might be threatening is rook
here the capture and then this Knight
jumping on d3 this is the one one square
I need to be a little bit cautious of
and well I'm winning a pawn here I guess
we're gonna have some exchange sacrifice
yes okay so did looking to break it open
maybe I should have never allowed that
you know what I should have just put my
knight there and not even allowed that
possibility would have been much cleaner
let me kick this Knight out of here
so now there's a material deficit but I
have to babysit my weaknesses over here
my pawns I'm not so quick to give this
guy up
and there's still a problem with this
bishop and this night I'm controlling a
lot of squares let's gotta get on a
half-open file this Bishop is now coming
to life let me let me continue with this
rook up and over to g4 yeah again I
think the big thing was that my opponent
did not have did not have what a good
pawn break that would help their
position Bishop takes pawn is now
threatened and that is being sniffed out
right away let's come here there's no
there's no time I guess the last thing I
could do is get my knight involved
there's not going to be any time okay
good game let's back up I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to give any advice
here let's see because I know how
difficult it could be once you get into
one particular structure
well let me point out this you need to
really be familiar with this resulting
structure if you're going to be playing
a six is black in this position if
you're not comfortable with this
structure I would try to do something
else because it could really turn into a
strategic crush again a position where
white maintains complete control over
the position and I've I've experienced
it on the black end I I'm speaking from
experience I know I know what it's like
to struggle from this position I've been
squeezed myself so after Queen to e2 I
think it's important to consider proof
to consider f6 it's quite weakening but
the idea behind it is to prevent this
'if I've advanced if you could somehow
get in f6e 5d6 we're in a whole new
world because the bishop can come out
much more freely a very nice diagonal a
very nice post on e6 so I wonder about
this f6 advance you need to be quite
familiar with the pawn structure the
different advances that are timely f6
might be one of them at this very moment
I would look into that but again if this
isn't something you're comfortable with
I would I would try to find something
other than maybe even east six
I wonder if Queen b6 or Queen c7 in the
event of a capture you're there to
recapture the Queen and keep your
structure as is but then again then
again you're wasting some time so I
could still be giving up the bishop for
Knight and then playing on the fact that
you're behind in development and I'll be
looking to open up the position so I
guess the the one thing to be pointing
out is I I would really be looking into
F sick
again I'm not a hundred percent sure on
it but um you have to be to be very very
careful we ended up getting into a
structure that is again favorable for
white I guess there's a lot of
instructional value in the form of pawn
structures in this particular game they
really dictate their the rest of the
game if there's an improvement again on
my end I think I wouldn't even have been
allowing this type of advance maybe I
would have committed my knight a bit
sooner I mean maybe it was still okay
keeping this Knight having some
flexibility with this Knight in the
event of d4 94 stuff but again it's a
favorable structure for white at this
point and it's I think again dating all
the way back to this moment right here
instead of Bishop e7 this pawn advance
or maybe even a move later after I play
d3 okay let me close out of this